This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In the 1960s, American cities were in crisis. Infrastructure was crumbling. Traffic and pollution were terrible. Crime was up. Cities weren't particularly nice places to live. White people were able to flee urban centers for the suburbs thanks to federal help with mortgages and new freeway development. That process would come to be known as White Flight. Meanwhile, black populations in cities were dealing with housing discrimination and police brutality. Riots were breaking out in cities all over the country, and this awful time was referred
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在 20世纪 60 年代，美国城市正处于危机之中。基础设施不断崩溃。交通和污染问题极其严重。犯罪率上升。城市并不是什么特别宜居的地方。由于联邦政府在抵押贷款和新高速公路建设方面提供的帮助，白人得以从城市中心逃往郊区。这一过程后来被称为“白人群飞”。与此同时，城市里的黑人人口正在应对住房歧视和警察暴力。骚乱在全国各地的城市爆发，这段糟糕的时期被
to by scholars as the urban crisis. That's our own Katie Mingo. And the civil rights movement was happening in parallel to the urban crisis, but it wasn't really addressing the problems for black people in cities. The overarching question was, can the cities be saved? How can we make urban life better for people, for all people? That's Roger Biles, professor of history at Illinois State University.
学者们称为城市危机。那是我们的凯蒂·明戈。民权运动与城市危机同时发生，但它并没有真正解决城市中黑人的问题。核心问题是：城市能被拯救吗？我们该如何为人们——为所有人——改善城市生活？那是罗杰·拜尔斯，伊利诺伊州立大学历史学教授。
And, you know, there were some folks who looked at the situation and just threw up their hands and said, you know, we just can't salvage what's here. The answer is starting over again. In other words, urban planners thought maybe the problems facing cities were too big and too complicated to fix. And it's within this context of the urban crisis and the civil rights movement that the federal government would come to consider an idea like Seoul City. Floyd McKissick offered an idea today, a new city to be built in the country in North Carolina to be called Seoul City and to be populated mainly
而且，你知道的，有一些人看着这种情况，直接双手一摊，说道：“你知道的，我们简直无法挽回这里的现状。唯一的办法就是重新开始。”换句话说，城市规划者认为，城市面临的问题可能太大、太复杂而无法解决。正是在这种城市危机和民权运动的背景下，联邦政府开始考虑像“灵魂城”这样的构想。弗洛伊德·麦基西克今天提出一个构想：在北卡罗来纳州的乡村建立一座新城市，名为“灵魂城”，他表示，这座城市将主要
or entirely by Negroes he says would move there from the ghettos. This tape is from a 1969 NBC National News broadcast and this new city was being proposed by a civil rights leader named Floyd McKissick. In establishing our new city in North Carolina, we will create new jobs and new careers for black people. As a response to the urban crisis, the federal government had announced plans to provide financing to about a dozen brand new towns and Floyd McKissick wanted Seoul City to be one of them.
或全部由那些他所说的将从贫民窟搬迁过去的黑人组成。这段录音摘自 1969 年 NBC 全国新闻广播，这座新城市是由一位名叫弗洛伊德·麦基西克的民权领袖提出的。“通过在北卡罗来纳州建立我们的新城，我们将为黑人创造新的工作和新的职业。”作为对城市危机的一种回应，联邦政府曾宣布计划为大约十几个崭新的城镇提供资金支持，而弗洛伊德·麦基西克希望“灵魂城”能成为其中之一。
In this new town, persons will be able to control their own destinies. We have the power to actually be a part of building a town. Come on, it's the story of America. And to be a part of it. That's Jane Ballgroom. She was working as a secretary from a chisic in Harlem when he first started developing the idea for Soul City, which would be a place built for and by black people, a land of black opportunity in rural North Carolina.
在这个新城镇里，人们将能够掌控自己的命运。我们有力量真正参与到城镇的建设中来。来吧，这就是美国的故事。并且成为其中的一部分。那是简·鲍尔格鲁姆。当麦基西克最初在哈莱姆开始构思“灵魂城”这个项目时，她曾在那里担任秘书。“灵魂城”将是一个专为黑人打造、由黑人建立的地方，是北卡罗来纳州乡村的一片黑人机遇之地。
Jane says going to Soul City was like being a pilgrim. You know, we had our own Mayflower ship, we came down in cars. You know, it was the same dog I'm saying. But, you know, maybe not so, the children's had a really hard. The pilgrims did have it really hard, but this wouldn't be easy either. The government would eventually come to support this project, but there would be politics and compromises and very strange bedfellows. And that was all before breaking ground on Soul City. When Floyd McKissick first pitched the idea of an all-black town, there was one
简说，去“灵魂城”就像是一场朝圣。“你知道的，我们有自己的五月花号船，我们是坐汽车南下的。你知道的，我说的是同一个道理。但是，你知道，也许并非如此，孩子们真的过得很艰难。”朝圣者的确过得很艰难，但这也不会轻松。政府最终会支持这个项目，但其中会有政治博弈、妥协以及非常奇怪的政治同盟。而这一切都发生在“灵魂城”破土动工之前。当弗洛伊德·麦基西克首次提出这个全黑人城镇的想法时，有一个
question he got asked a lot. There's a building in a city like this, four-mpire of the trend towards separatism. This is a reporter at an early press conference and a lot of people were curious about this. With Soul City a departure from the idea that black people and white people should integrate together in society? Was this instead black people starting their own thing separate from white people? And you can hear mccasics struggle to answer. Now I think it does the same thing as the Chinese have done in New York. They built them Chinese area, Chinatown.
问题他经常被问到。“这在像这样的城市里建立，是否会助长分裂主义的趋势？”这是一位记者在早期新闻发布会上提出的问题，很多人对此很好奇。“‘灵魂城’是否背离了黑人和白人在社会中应当共同融合的理念？这反而是黑人开创脱离白人的独立事业吗？”你能听到麦基西克在艰难地回答。“现在我认为这和中国人在纽约做的事情是一样的。他们建造了中国城，华人区。”
It's a beautiful section of the city that I admire. To understand all the ways that this question about separatism was relevant, you have to understand a bit about who Floyd McKissick was. This photograph here would kill my father, I'm the left here hand in hand with Dr. King. This is Floyd McKissick the second. He's a lawyer and a state senator and he's showing me pictures of his dad that are hanging in his office in Durham, North Carolina. Three of the famous Mark and Washington, where Dr. King gave his eye at a dream speech.
“那是城市中一个美丽的部分，我很赞赏。”为了理解关于这种分裂主义的种种质疑为何切中要害，你必须对弗洛伊德·麦基西克其人有一定了解。“这张照片真的让我父亲……我左边这位正和马丁·路德·金博士手挽着手。”这是小弗洛伊德·麦基西克。他是一名律师兼州参议员，他正在他位于北卡罗来纳州达勒姆的办公室里向我展示挂在那里的他父亲的照片。“华盛顿大游行三杰之一，金博士在那里发表了‘我有一个梦想’的演讲。”
My father and Dr. King led that mark that day. A few years after that march, Floyd McKissick's senior would become the executive director of an organization called CORE. That's the Congress on racial equality. And he was part of a handful of really important civil rights leaders in the 60s, along with people like Dr. King, Roy Wilkins, and Anna Blacepie, Whitney Young of the Urban League, and Stokely Carmichael of SNCC.
“我父亲和金博士那天领导了那场游行。”那次游行几年后，老弗洛伊德·麦基西克成为了一个名为 CORE 的组织的执行主任。也就是种族平等大会。他是 60 年代少数几位真正重要的民权领袖之一，与金博士、罗伊·威尔金斯、阿纳·布莱斯皮（译者注：此处为人名误读组合，通常指小阿瑟·邦内尔/厄尔·布朗等，但按音频多指城市联盟的惠特尼·杨以及 SNCC 的斯托克利·卡迈克尔）、城市联盟的惠特尼·杨以及 SNCC 的斯托克利·卡迈克尔等人齐名。
SNCC being the student nonviolent coordinating committee. Because of these leaders and the members of their organizations, huge legal gains were made in civil rights and integration in the 50s and 60s. And then in 1966 there's this kind of pivotal moment in the movement. A civil rights activist named James Meredith is shot by a white gunman while leading a march in Mississippi. Stokely Carmichael and Floyd McKissick both go down in Mississippi to continue the march. Carmichael is arrested and when he gets out of jail he makes a speech where he says, don't be afraid, don't be ashamed, we want black power. We want black power.
SNCC 即学生非暴力协调委员会。正是由于这些领袖及其组织成员的努力，50 和 60 年代在民权和种族融合方面取得了巨大的法律成果。然后在 1966 年，运动中迎来了这样一个关键时刻。一位名叫詹姆斯·梅雷迪思的民权活动家在密西西比州领导游行时被一名白人枪手击中。斯托克利·卡迈克尔和弗洛伊德·麦基西克双双前往密西西比州继续游行。卡迈克尔被捕了，当他出狱时，他发表了一场演讲，其中说道：“不要害怕，不要羞愧，我们要黑人权。我们要黑人权。”
We want black power. We want black power. We have stayed here and we beg the president. We beg the federal government. That's all we've been doing, begging, begging. It's time we stand up and take over. On that day in 1966, the president was going to be the president.
“我们要黑人权。我们要黑人权。我们一直留在这里，我们乞求总统。我们乞求联邦政府。这就是我们一直在做的，乞求，乞求。是时候我们站起来接管一切了。”在 1966 年的那一天，总统将成为……
He was going to be the president. He was going to be the president, we beg the federal government. That's all we've been doing, begging, begging, is time we stand up and take over. On that day in 1966, the Black Power Movement was born. And the mechistic of core and Carmichael of SNCC become two of the most vocal advocates of this new movement. What do we need, Black Power? When do we need it now? Stoking my dad were probably the two
他将成为总统。他将成为总统，我们乞求联邦政府。这就是我们一直在做的事，乞求，乞求，是时候我们站起来接管一切了。在 1966 年的那一天，黑人权力运动诞生了。CORE 的麦基西克和 SNCC 的卡迈克尔成为了这一新运动最直言不讳的倡导者。我们需要什么？黑人权力！我们什么时候需要？现在！斯托克利和我爸爸可能是阐明
leaders in articulating what that meant. For Carmichael and McKissick, black power was a step further than civil rights and integration. It was essentially the idea that black people should control their own communities, should have proportional representation in government. Again, Stokely Carmichael in 1966. We have to do what every group in this country did. We got to take over the communities where we outnumber people so we can have decent jobs. So we can have decent houses. So we can have decent roads.
这意味着什么的两大领袖。对于卡迈克尔和麦基西克来说，黑人权力比民权和种族融合更进了一步。它本质上的理念是：黑人应该控制自己的社区，应该在政府中拥有按比例的代表权。再次引用 1966 年斯托克利·卡迈克尔的话。“我们必须做这个国家每一个群体都做过的事。我们要接管那些我们人口占优势的社区，这样我们就能拥有体面的工作。这样我们就能拥有体面的住房。这样我们就能拥有体面的道路。”
So we can have decent schools. So we can have decent justice. So we can have decent justice. So, McKissick and Carmichael both very much believed in the idea of black power. But in the late 60s, they began to diverge about how to achieve it. Carmichael and many others in the black power movement thought that capitalism was an inherently exploitative system that would always leave someone at the bottom. On the other hand, McKissick began to believe that capitalism was the answer. McKissick actually associates himself with a very important tendency in black power.
“这样我们就能拥有体面的学校。这样我们就能拥有体面的司法。这样我们就能拥有体面的司法。”所以，麦基西克和卡迈克尔都非常笃信黑人权力的理念。但在 60 年代后期，他们在如何实现这一目标上开始出现分歧。卡迈克尔和黑人权力运动中的许多其他人认为，资本主义本质上是一种剥削制度，总会把某些人踩在社会底层。另一方面，麦基西克开始相信资本主义才是答案。麦基西克实际上将自己与黑人权力中一个非常重要的倾向联系在了一起。
That Sundiara Chajua, professor of history and African American studies at the University of Illinois or Banna Champaign, and the tendency he's talking about is one toward black capitalism. What it means, essentially, is that black people should own and control their own capitalist enterprises, and it comes to suggest that business ownership is to path to equality, freedom, justice, social transformation. Too long ago we attempted to divide economics from politics. The question that becomes paramount in say 1970 is a strategy not principle. That's Floyd McKissick, an archival interview with political writer Walter DeVries. We see the subject is becoming intensely pragmatic to us. Absolutely. Absolutely.
伊利诺伊大学厄巴纳-香槟分校的历史与非裔美国人研究教授孙迪亚拉·查朱如说道，他所指的这种倾向就是黑人资本主义。其本质含义是，黑人应该拥有并控制自己的资本企业，这也暗示了企业所有权通往平等、自由、正义和社会变革的道路。曾几何时，我们试图将经济学与政治学割裂开来。比如说在 1970 年，至关重要的问题变成了一种策略而非原则。这是弗洛伊德·麦基西克在与政治作家沃尔特·德弗里斯的档案访谈中的言论。“我们看到这个主题对我们变得具有强烈的实用主义色彩。绝对是的。绝对是的。”
As you've got it with the ideological and the ideological. You don't have to call it pragmatic. You might lose everything that you've gained, all those gains that you've made during the 60s. McKissick believed that the time for idealism was over. It was time for black people to claim their piece of the American pie. Now where the hell are you and what the where, what are you going to do to become a fool fled America? Do you want to go back to Africa? I for one believe I will stay here. Actually, Stokely Carmichael did go to Africa.
“正如你所拥有的意识形态和意识形态。你不必称之为实用主义。你可能会失去你所赢得的一切，失去你在 60 年代取得的所有成果。”麦基西克认为，理想主义的时代已经结束。现在是黑人争取属于他们的美国梦的时候了。现在你到底在哪里，你打算怎么做才能成为一个成熟的美国人？你想回非洲吗？我个人相信我会留在这里。事实上，斯托克利·卡迈克尔确实去了非洲。
Leaving behind the black Power movement in America, he moved to Guinea, where he dedicated himself to the all African People's Revolutionary Party. And Floyd McKissick did indeed stay in the States. He resigned from core to start a four-profit company called McKissick Enterprises, and set his sights on building Seoul City. The town he hoped would create as much economic opportunity for black Americans as possible.
他抛下了美国的黑人权力运动，搬到了几内亚，在那里投身于泛非人民革命党。而弗洛伊德·麦基西克确实留在了美国。他辞去了 CORE 的职务，创办了一家名为“麦基西克企业”的营利性公司，并将目光投向了建设“灵魂城”。他希望这座城镇能为美籍黑人创造尽可能多的经济机遇。
And we can bring together, you know, the private sector. You can bring together industry government and educational resources to really build a town free of racism. the town free of racism. The building of black towns is an expression of a desire for autonomy. McKissick's soul city wasn't a first for black town building in the US. Quite a few towns were settled in the great plains between 1890 and 1910 by African-American sharecroppers fleeing the south, but these weren't intentionally planned communities with government support. Amazingly in the late 1960s, just as McKissick becomes convinced that building a new town
“我们可以汇聚私营部门的力量。你可以汇聚工业、政府和教育资源，真正建设一个没有种族主义的城镇。”一个没有种族主义的城镇。黑人城镇的建设是对自治渴望的一种表达。麦基西克的“灵魂城”并不是美国黑人城镇建设的首例。在 1890 年至 1910 年间，大平原上有相当多的城镇是由逃离南方的非裔美国佃农建立的，但这些并不是有政府支持的有计划的社区。令人惊奇的是，在 20 世纪 60 年代末，正当麦基西克确信建设新城镇
is the way to achieve black power, the government struggling to deal with the so-called urban crisis announces their program to help finance several new cities as part of the Urban Growth and new Communities Act. The legislation was passed, which provided a process for building these things. That's historian Roger Biles again, and he says these new cities would be meticulously planned in order to avoid the problems of existing cities. We're going to bring all of the knowledge and all of the insights of urban planning to doing it right this time. The program would be managed by the U.S. Department of Housing and Urban Development, also known as HUD. Private developers could propose ideas to HUD for new towns. If they were approved, the new towns could sell government-backed bonds to investors on Wall Street.
是实现黑人权力的途径时，正艰难应对所谓城市危机的政府宣布了一项新计划，旨在作为《城市发展与新社区法》的一部分，帮助资助几个新城市。该立法获得通过，为建设这些项目提供了流程。历史学家罗杰·拜尔斯再次说道，他表示这些新城镇将被精心规划，以避免现有城市的问题。“我们将运用城市规划的所有知识和远见，这一次要把事情做好。”该计划将由美国住房和城市发展部（也称为 HUD）管理。私人开发商可以向 HUD 提出新城镇的构想。如果获得批准，这些新城镇就可以向华尔街的投资者出售政府担保的债券。
And as McKissick starts talking to people within HUD about this all-black town idea, they're like, look, there's no way we're going to approve something that's perceived as being separatist. So McKissick dials back the language he was using to describe Seoul City. If you look at the things that he wrote and said before he feels out to actual applications, right, it's all about, you know, he's talking about building ideal black communities.
正当麦基西克开始与 HUD 内部的人士谈论这个全黑人城镇的想法时，他们的反应是：“听着，我们绝不可能批准任何被视为具有分裂主义色彩的项目。”因此，麦基西克淡化了他用来描述“灵魂城”的语言。如果你看看他在提交实际申请之前所写和所说的话，就会发现，这全都是关于……他谈论的是建设理想的黑人社区。
After he's gone through that process, then the literature is about building middle class communities that are open. McKissick never envisioned a place where white people would be specifically excluded. He did imagine a majority black town with a majority black leadership, but he couldn't really talk about it like that. In politics, concessions must be made. The next big one would come in the form of an important ally.
在他经历了这一流程之后，相关的文献和宣传就变成了关于建设开放的中产阶级社区。麦基西克从未设想过一个明确排挤白人的地方。他确实设想过一个以黑人为主、由黑人领导层主导的城镇，但他实际上不能那样直言不讳。在政治中，必须做出妥协。下一个重大妥协将以一个重要盟友的形式出现。
Mckissick understood that to be approved to build one of these new cities, he'd need friends in high places. He first pitches the idea to the current president, Lyndon Johnson. And Johnson seems interested, but then he decides not to run for re-election. And so, in 1968, Mckissick looks at the new field of presidential candidates and asks himself, who is the most viable person to support the Seoul City Project? That's Devon Fergis. He's a professor of African American Studies at Ohio State University.
麦基西克明白，要想获准建设这些新城镇之一，他需要在高层有朋友。他首先向当时的总统林登·约翰逊提出了这个构想。约翰逊似乎很感兴趣，但他随后决定不再竞选连任。因此，在 1968 年，麦基西克审视了新一届总统候选人阵营，并问自己：谁是对支持“灵魂城”项目最切实可行的人选？那是德文·弗格斯。他是俄亥俄州立大学非裔美国人研究教授。
He opts for Richard Nixon. We've had enough of big promises and little action. The time has come for honest government in the United States of America. And it's chocolately. Nixon actually supports this project. Nixon believed in black capitalism because Nixon believed in capitalism. He believed that when people owned property and businesses, they had more of a stake in the country. Apart from that, the Republican Party wanted to bring in black voters. In Republican Party in the late 60s and 70s was a much more big tinted sort of party.
他选择了理查德·尼克松。“我们已经受够了宏大的承诺和微不足道的行动。美利坚合众国诚实政府的时代已经到来。”而且令人高兴的是，尼克松实际上支持这个项目。尼克松相信黑人资本主义，因为尼克松相信资本主义。他相信，当人们拥有财产和企业时，他们对这个国家就会有更多的投资和参与感。除此之外，共和党希望争取黑人选民。60 年代末和 70 年代的共和党是一个包容度大得多的政党。
The way to win and a way to create a doorbell to Republican party, is by casting as wide as net is possible. It's unclear how much Nixon's support helped McKesics cause since the final decision was made by an agency within HUD. But in the early 1970s, Seoul City did become one of the 13 new towns to receive government backing. And Floyd McKesic, Black Power Leader, became a Republican, and one of Nixon's most vocal black supporters. Of the 13 new cities, Seoul City was the only so-called free-standing new city.
赢得选举并为共和党建立基础力量的方法，就是尽可能撒下最宽的网。目前尚不清楚尼克松的支持对麦基西克的诉求起到了多大帮助，因为最终决定是由 HUD 内部的一个机构做出的。但在 20 世纪 70 年代初，“灵魂城”确实成为了获得政府支持的 13 个新城镇之一。而黑人权力领袖弗洛伊德·麦基西克也成为了一名共和党人，并成为了尼克松最直言不讳的黑人支持者之一。在这 13 个新城市中，“灵魂城”是唯一一个所谓的独立式新城市。
Meaning, it wasn't being built right next to an already existing city that it could lean on for employment opportunities and infrastructure. It was being built on an old tobacco plantation, about an hour away from Durham in rural Warren County, North Carolina. We were partying ears. We really were partying ears because you have to know what this place looked like. It was a farm, it was the green-due plantation. Well, it was in high form. There were only 59 slaves there.
这意味着，它不是建在某个可以依靠其提供就业机会和基础设施的现有城市旁边。它是建在一个旧烟草种植园上，距离北卡罗来纳州沃伦县乡村的达勒姆大约一个小时车程。“我们当时在狂欢。我们真的在狂欢，因为你必须知道这个地方以前是什么样子。它是一个农场，它是格林露种植园。嗯，它曾经非常兴旺。那里只有 59 个奴隶。”
That's Jane Ballgroom. You heard her at the beginning of the story and Doris Terry Williams. I interviewed them together in Jane's house in Warren County. In 1970, Jane packed up her family and left her crowded housing project in New York for the wide open farmlands of North Carolina. For me, coming out of New York was land! It was land! It was safe! When Jane got to Warren County, there were just a handful of other new settlers living in trailers.
那是简·鲍尔格鲁姆。你在故事开头听过她的声音，还有多丽丝·特里·威廉姆斯。我在沃伦县简的家里一起采访了她们。1970 年，简收拾好行装，带着家人离开了纽约拥挤的住房项目，来到北卡罗来纳州广阔开阔的农田。对我来说，从纽约出来就是土地！那是土地！那是安全！当简到达沃伦县时，只有寥寥可数的其他新定居者住在拖车里。
These early planners had developed a 30-year strategy for Solciti that laid out everything, including their plan for three residential villages with mixed income housing. Floyd McKinseyck II actually got a degree in urban planning to help his dad design Solciti. The design was inspired by the plan community of Columbia, Maryland, which was meant to have racial diversity and a small town feel. Solciti had acquired 3 3600 acres of land. They hoped to have a population of about 2000 people by 1978 and by the end of 30 years they wanted to be up to around 40,000 people. Jane says these early days at
这些早期的规划者为“灵魂城”制定了一项为期 30 年的战略，其中规划了一切，包括他们关于三个带有混合收入住房的住宅村的计划。小弗洛伊德·麦基西克甚至获得了城市规划学位来帮他父亲设计“灵魂城”。该设计灵感来源于马里兰州哥伦比亚的规划社区，该社区旨在拥有种族多样性和小镇风情。“灵魂城”已经收购了 3600 英亩的土地。他们希望到 1978 年人口能达到 2000 人左右，到 30 年结束时，他们希望人口能增加到 40,000 人左右。简说，这些早期在
Sol City just felt full of potential. Growing up in America even in New York, you know you have limitations because you were Negro. You have to understand that. You can't understand that. You've got my point and then you hear you get all of this. Oh my God! It's a miracle. It was to me it was just an amazing time to be young, gifted in black. Floyd McKissick continued to support the Republican Party, and he spent some time traveling and campaigning for Nixon when he ran for his second term as president. But most of McKissick's time was spent at Seoul City.
“灵魂城”的日子充满了潜力。“在美国长大，即使在纽约，你也知道自己有限制，因为你是黑人。你必须明白这一点。你无法理解这一点。你懂我的意思，然后你来到这里，得到了这一切。哦，天哪！这简直是个奇迹。对我来说，这是一个年轻、有天赋且身为黑人的绝佳时代。”弗洛伊德·麦基西克继续支持共和党，并在尼克松竞选第二任总统期间花了一些时间四处奔走为他竞选拉票。但麦基西克的大部分时间都花在了“灵魂城”。
When he was here, he was in the middle of the community. He was never a part of above. You know, I didn't have his education, I didn't have his stature, but he was my brother. Yeah. McKissick had decided on Warren County because he grown up in North Carolina, so we knew the state. But also because black residents had left the South in droves during the great migration to cities of the North,
当他在这里时，他就身处社区的中心。他从来不是高高在上的人。“你知道的，我没有他的教育背景，我没有他的声望，但他就像我的兄弟。”是的。麦基西克之所以选定沃伦县，是因为他在北卡罗来纳州长大，所以他对这个州很熟悉。而且也是因为在伟大的迁徙潮中，黑人居民成群结队地离开南方前往北方城市，
he wanted to give urban blacks a place in the South to return to if they wanted, and give people who were already there a reason to stay. In order to create jobs, McKissick's hope was to attract industry. He wanted a big company, like General Motors, to come down and build a factory. But before that could happen, Sol City needed basic infrastructure, like water and electric. Sol City built an electrical grid
他想为城市黑人提供一个可以返回南方的落脚点（如果他们愿意的话），并为已经留在那里的居民提供一个留下的理由。为了创造就业机会，麦基西克的愿望是吸引工业入驻。他希望像通用汽车这样的大公司下来建一座工厂。但在那之前，“灵魂城”需要基本的基础设施，比如水和电。“灵魂城”建设了一个电网，
and partnered with a few other counties to build a huge regional water system from a nearby lake. Between 74 and 76, there was this growth. I'd wake up in the morning, I'd hear bulldozers outside, I'd see the trucks coming in, digging up the bread and mud, putting down concrete. I saw this every day, you smelled it, it was just so fantastic.
并与另外几个县合作，从附近的湖泊修建了一个巨大的区域性供水系统。在 74 到 76 年间，这里出现了这种增长。我每天早晨醒来，听到外面推土机的轰鸣，看到卡车开进来，挖开满是泥泞的土地，铺设混凝土。我每天都看到这些，你还能闻到它的气味，简直太棒了。
So many things were... They built a health clinic called HealthCo in a public swimming pool, both of which brought people from all over the county. The roads, all the roads, all the roads, the house, the infrastructure. And they built a huge 60,000 square foot industrial building divided into separate sections with loading docks called Soul Tech 1. Soul Tech 1 completed in 1975 was designed by architect Harvey Gantt and it was meant to be an incubator where a new industry could get started and then move to bigger facilities if need be.
许多事情都在……他们建造了一个名为 HealthCo 的健康诊所和一个公共游泳池，这两者都吸引了全县各地的人们。道路，所有的道路，所有的道路，房屋，基础设施。他们建造了一座巨大的 60,000 平方英尺的工业建筑，分为不同的区域并带有装卸货台，名为 Soul Tech 1。于 1975 年完工的 Soul Tech 1 由建筑师哈维·甘特设计，旨在成为一个孵化器，让新兴产业在此起步，如有必要再迁移到更大的设施中。
But despite there being moments where it felt like real growth was happening, Seoul City was not hitting its targets. By the mid-1970s, the population was fewer than 200 people. A few small manufacturers set up in the Seoul Tech building, but no one that could offer a substantial number of jobs. Without enough residence, it was hard to attract industry, and without the industry, it was hard to attract new residents. And then there was the problem of the name.
但尽管有时感觉真正的增长正在发生，“灵魂城”并没有达到其预定目标。到 20 世纪 70 年代中期，人口不足 200 人。一些小型制造商在 Soul Tech 大楼里落户，但没有一家能够提供大量的就业机会。没有足够的居民，就很难吸引工业；而没有工业，又很难吸引新居民。接着还有名字的问题。
And then the name, Soul City. I mean, there were people who said you should change the name of the project and though, you know, Floyd just refused to do that. It was really terrific. It's biblical. You had a soul. We had three souls on my soul first. It was a time to receive the name as being to black. To black. Soul City was not an all-black town. In fact, Gordon Carey, who played an important role in the leadership, was white, and some
还有名字，灵魂城。我的意思是，有些人说你应该改掉这个项目的名字，而你知道的，弗洛伊德就是拒绝这样做。这真的很了不起。这很有《圣经》色彩。你拥有灵魂。我们最早在我的灵魂里有三个灵魂。当时有一种看法，认为这个名字太黑了。太黑了。“灵魂城”并不是一个全黑人的城镇。事实上，在领导层中扮演重要角色的戈登·凯里是白人，而且一些
of the residents were white. But it could never really escape the perception of being an all-black town. And in some ways, it never really wanted to. So many people over the years have said, oh, you know, why was it all black? I've gotten old enough to say now. Why not? It was a multiracial community, it always was. But don't go on it.
居民也是白人。但它始终无法摆脱被视为全黑人城镇的公众印象。在某些方面，它也从没真正想摆脱这一点。这些年来，很多人都说：“哦，你知道的，为什么它全是黑人？”我现在已经长大到可以说：“为什么不呢？这是一个多民族的社区，一直都是。”但别去深究。
After all the years that we've been through, and I'm like, my history, why not? Apart from Soul City's identity issues, McKisix ally in the White House, President Nixon, had resigned in disgrace, and the economy was in a slump. On top of that, the Raleigh News Observer launched an expose on Sol City. 17 negative articles over eight days accusing Sol City of all kinds of wrongdoing, political payoffs, cronism, nepotism, and financial misappropriation.
在我们经历了所有这些岁月的风雨之后，就像我的历史一样，为什么不呢？除了“灵魂城”的身份认同问题之外，麦基西克在白宫的盟友——尼克松总统因丑闻辞职，经济也陷入低迷。最重要的是，《罗利新闻与观察报》对“灵魂城”展开了一次深度曝光调查。在八天时间里连续发表了 17 篇负面文章，指责“灵魂城”存在种种不端行为、政治利益输送、任人唯亲、裙带关系以及资金滥用。
And then, with this expose as rationale, came North Carolina's senator, Jesse Helms, ready to battle with Soul City. Here's Floyd McKissick the second again. Helms launched attacks against Soul City that literally brought development to a halt. During his long tenure as a Republican senator in North Carolina, Jesse Helms gained the reputation of being a not-so-secret racist, and he disliked the Sol City project from the beginning. Remember, McKissick and Helms were in the same political party.
接着，借着这篇曝光报道作为借口，北卡罗来纳州参议员杰西·赫尔姆斯登场了，准备与“灵魂城”展开较量。这里再次请出小弗洛伊德·麦基西克。赫尔姆斯对“灵魂城”发起了攻击，这让开发建设工作直接陷入了停顿。在他作为北卡罗来纳州共和党参议员的漫长任期内，杰西·赫尔姆斯落得了“毫不掩饰的种族主义者”的名声，他从一开始就不喜欢“灵魂城”项目。记住，麦基西克和赫尔姆斯属于同一个政党。
Still, Helms was determined to destroy McKissick's city. Senator Helms ordered a fiscal audit on Sol City, and HUD froze funding until the audit was over. They never found any wrongdoing. The audit gave us a clean bill of health, but it damaged us significantly in terms of public perceptions. It's true most of the charges leveled against Seoul City by Helms or the Rally News and Observer were not substantiated during the audit, But the bad press had further scared away industry and investors.
尽管如此，赫尔姆斯还是决心摧毁麦基西克的城市。赫尔姆斯参议员下令对“灵魂城”进行财务审计，在审计结束之前，HUD 冻结了资金。他们从未发现任何违规行为。“审计结果证明我们清白，但在公众认知方面对我们造成了沉重的打击。”确实，赫尔姆斯或《罗利新闻与观察报》对“灵魂城”提出的指控大都没有在审计中得到证实，但负面新闻进一步吓退了工业界和投资者。
Growth in Seoul City was at a standstill. And after a certain point, again, historian Roger Biles. Bankers and HUD simply withdrew to the position that, well, we're not going to advance you any more loans. We're not going to invest in this anymore until we see some growth. And McKissicks come back, well, you know, we've reached a point where the growth isn't going to come unless we have more investment. This business didn't come, that business didn't come. Things were not looking great. But in my mind being the optimist that I am a civil, but it's going to happen, it's going to be okay. Ten years ago Floyd McKissick, a civil rights activist, set out to build a city for blacks.
“灵魂城”的发展陷入了停滞。历史学家罗杰·拜尔斯再次指出，在某个时间点之后，银行家和 HUD 简单地退缩到了这样的立场：“好吧，在看到一些增长之前，我们不会再向你们发放任何贷款。我们不会再投资这个项目了。”而麦基西克的反击则是：“嗯，你知道的，我们已经到了这样一个地步：如果不投入更多的资金，就不会有增长。”这家企业没有来，那家企业也没有来。情况看起来不太妙。但在我看来，作为一个乐观主义者的我，事情会发生的，一切都会好起来的。十年前，民权活动家弗洛伊德·麦基西克着手为黑人建立一座城市。
McKissick said that in 30 years it would be home to 46,000 people. But today, Seoul City is a broken dream and the government has begun for closure action to seize the property. In 1979, HUD announced that they would no longer support Sol City. Without the government support, McKissick was forced into foreclosure, and most of the land at Sol City was sold off. But of the 13 towns developed as part of the Urban Growth and New Communities Act, Sol City wasn't the only one to fail. Only one of them actually thrived and that was a place called the Woodlands, which is just north of Houston.
麦基西克曾表示，30 年后这里将容纳 46,000 人。但今天，“灵魂城”是一个破灭的梦想，政府已经开始采取止赎行动来没收这些财产。1979 年，HUD 宣布将不再支持“灵魂城”。失去政府支持后，麦基西克被迫面临资产抵押品赎回权介入（止赎），“灵魂城”的大部分土地被变卖。但在作为《城市发展与新社区法》一部分而开发的 13 个城镇中，“灵魂城”并不是唯一一个失败的项目。其中只有唯一一个真正蓬勃发展，那就是名为“伍德兰兹”的地方，它位于休斯敦正北方。
The Woodlands was more generously subsidized from the beginning and had the benefit of being on the outskirts of Houston, Texas during an oil boom. The other 12 towns all failed, meaning people might still live there, but they did not continue on autonomously. Some became suburbs or neighborhoods of bigger towns, some remained unincorporated. Most of the failed towns cited a lack of investment as the primary reason for failure. But Sol City faced additional hurdles. For one, they were the only standalone town, so they were truly starting from nothing. And in that, it's that a strong dose of racism.
“伍德兰兹”从一开始就获得了更慷慨的补贴，并且得益于在石油繁荣时期处于得克萨斯州休斯敦的郊区这一优势。其他 12 个城镇全部失败了，这意味着人们可能仍然住在那里，但它们并没有继续自主发展。有些变成了更大城镇的郊区或社区，有些则保持着非建制区状态。大多数失败的城镇都将缺乏投资列为失败的主要原因。但“灵魂城”面临着额外的阻碍。首先，它是唯一的独立城镇，所以它们真的是从零开始。在这其中，还包含着一剂强烈的种族主义。
I think that might be the way you laugh when you actually want to scream. In any case, it's not hard to imagine that racism played a role in Sol City's demise. There was the investigation by Jesse Helms, the negative press, and the government Floyd Jr. says was always looking over their shoulder. We were always under a special level of scrutiny, and a special level of review. You're gonna make the right turn at that yellow sign down there.
我想这也许就是当你实际上想尖叫时发出的那种笑声吧。无论如何，不难想象种族主义在“灵魂城”的消亡中发挥了作用。有杰西·赫尔姆斯的调查、负面媒体报道，还有小弗洛伊德所说的那种总是对他们虎视眈眈的政府。我们一直处于特殊的审视级别和特殊的审查级别之下。“你将在前面那个黄色路标处右转。”
That was the main entrance to Soul City. I'm going to make the right turn at that yellow sign down there. That was the main entrance to Sol City. I'm driving around with Doris Terri Williams in what was once Sol City. It's now an unincorporated part of Warren County. This little strip right here was built as the beginning of kind of a commercial place. There were several little businesses in there. It still feels like a really rural area. There's a pond and some woods,
那是“灵魂城”的正门。“我将在前面那个黄色路标处右转。那是‘灵魂城’的正门。”我和多丽丝·特里·威廉姆斯一起开车兜风，穿行于曾经的“灵魂城”。这里现在是沃伦县的一个非建制区。眼前这小片地带当初被建为商业区雏形的一部分。那里曾有几家小店铺。这里感觉仍然像是一个非常乡村的区域。有一个池塘和一些树林，
a few clusters of houses. Some of the buildings are abandoned, like the health clinic. And this building here on your left, this was health co. Health co. And then we get to a new building, a big one. One that was built after the Soul City project failed. And this is the prison. In 1993, the Warren County Correctional Facility was built. It's a high-security prison designed to house about 800 inmates. And next door to the prison, and the building that used to be Soltech 1, is now Correction
几处零星的房屋。有些建筑已被废弃，比如健康诊所。左手边的这栋建筑，这就是 HealthCo。HealthCo。然后我们来到了一座新建筑，一栋大楼。“灵魂城”项目失败后建造的建筑。这就是监狱。1993 年，沃伦县惩教设施建成。这是一座旨在容纳约 800 名犯人的高度戒备监狱。监狱隔壁，也就是曾经的 Soul Tech 1 大楼，现在成了惩教
Enterprises. Soltech 1, remember, was the building designed to incubate new industry in Sol City. At Correction Enterprises, prison laborers make genitorial products like soap and earn about three dollars a day. All of this on the former slave plantation that Floyd McKisic tried to transform into a place for black people to succeed. It's not hard to see the tragic irony in this. Back at Jane's house, I asked her and Doris how they felt when the prison came. I lost my freaking mind, I'm her and Doris how they felt when the prison came. I lost my freaking mind. I'm beginning to say she...
企业公司。大家还记得，Soul Tech 1 是旨在“灵魂城”孵化新兴产业的建筑。在惩教企业公司，监狱劳工制作肥皂等清洁用品，每天大约赚三美元。这一切都发生在弗洛伊德·麦基西克试图将其转变为黑人成功之地的昔日奴隶种植园上。不难看出其中悲剧性的讽刺意味。回到简的家里，我问她和多丽丝，当监狱建起来时她们是什么感受。我简直气疯了。我问她和多丽丝当监狱建起来时她们是什么感受。我简直气疯了。我开始说她……
And they could have brought industry here, real industry. Yeah, why not? Instead of that prison. Bringing a prison because most of the men with black prisons are black. It happens all over rural America, particularly low income and communities of color, but the promise that is going to bring jobs. It is an insult, is an insult to Floyd's memory, is an insult to all the things that he was trying to do here. Floyd McKissick passed away in 1991, so he didn't live to see this final insult to his city.
他们本可以在这里引进工业，真正的工业。是的，为什么不呢？而不是那座监狱。引进一座监狱，因为关押的犯人大多数是黑人。这种情况在全美乡村地区屡见不鲜，尤其是低收入和有色人种社区，但它承诺会带来就业机会。这是对弗洛伊德记忆的侮辱，是对他在这里试图做的一切事情的侮辱。弗洛伊德·麦基西克于 1991 年去世，所以他没有活着看到对他的城市的最后这桩侮辱。
Before he died, he served as a judge in North Carolina and as a pastor at the first Baptist Church of Seoul City. He found a way to continue the struggle. But Seoul City was a hard defeat to get over. This was his architecture. This was his fountain head. This was his, this was, it is, and it is his legacy. I mean, can you imagine? And I tell you, I saw a difference in him. He was just a different man. Something had been shaken away. He wouldn't tell you, but something had been shaken away.
在他去世之前，他曾担任北卡罗来纳州的法官以及“灵魂城”第一浸信会教堂的牧师。他找到了一种继续抗争的方法。但“灵魂城”是一个很难走出来的惨痛失败。这是他的建筑设计。这是他的源泉。这是他的，这是，它是，而且它是他的遗产。我的意思是，你能想象吗？我告诉你，我看到他发生了变化。他完全成了另一个人。有什么东西被击碎了。他不会告诉你，但有什么东西被击碎了。
It's funny, somehow I'd never heard of McKessick. I'd heard of a lot of his contemporaries in civil rights, Martin Luther King Jr. of course Roy Wilkins and Whitney Young. I'd also heard of a lot of his peers in the Black Power movement, people like Stokely Carmichael, Asada Shakur, Huey Newton and Angela Davis, but not Floyd McKissick. These younger scholars who do what's called Black Power Studies, they've tended to study and write about the organizations and the individuals whom they see as heroic. That's Professor Sundiata Chajua again.
有趣的是，不知怎的，我以前从未听说过麦基西克。我听说过很多他在民权运动时期的同代人，比如马丁·路德·金、罗伊·威尔金斯和惠特尼·杨。我也听说过他在黑人权力运动中的许多同僚，比如斯托克利·卡迈克尔、阿萨达·沙库尔、休伊·牛顿和安吉拉·戴维斯，但就是没有听说过弗洛伊德·麦基西克。这些年轻学者从事所谓的黑人权力研究，他们倾向于研究和撰写那些他们视为英雄的组织和个人。孙迪亚拉·查朱如教授再次说道。
Mckissick supports Richard M. Nixon and joins the Republican Party. Mckissick isn't seen as heroic, but that doesn't mean he's not important. Sundata thinks that even though Mckissick was not a conservative Republican, he's still a less appealing character to scholars who are interested in the more radical ideals generally associated with black power. So he gets written out of the history. Mckissick is fairly well known and loved in North Carolina. And Doris says Sol City has had far reaching impacts on the state.
麦基西克支持理查德·M·尼克松并加入共和党。麦基西克不被视为英雄，但这并不意味着他不重要。孙迪亚拉认为，尽管麦基西克不是保守派共和党人，但对于那些对通常与黑人权力相关的更激进理想感兴趣的学者来说，他仍然是一个吸引力较小的人物。因此他被写出了历史。麦基西克在北卡罗来纳州相当知名且备受爱戴。多丽丝说，“灵魂城”对该州产生了深远的影响。
Because do you think about the people who came through Sol City who have gone on to do just amazing thing? I was talking to Abdullah Rashid the other day. Doris and Jane go on to list several people who were influenced by McKissick and Soul City and went on to start social programs in the area or even be elected to public office. You know, Eva Clayton, all of the folk who came through. And people still live on the land that was Soul City, making use of the water and electrical
因为想想那些经由“灵魂城”走出并继续做出惊人成就的人们？我前几天还在和阿卜杜拉·拉希德交谈。多丽丝和简接着列举了几个受麦基西克和“灵魂城”影响的人，他们后来在该地区发起了社会项目，甚至当选为公职人员。“你知道的，埃娃·克莱顿，所有那些从这里走出来的人。”人们依然住在曾是“灵魂城”的土地上，使用着作为项目一部分而修建的水电
systems that were built as part of the project, driving on those roads, living in those houses. Jane Ballgroom still owns her home in Sol City. I mean, to me, Mackissac's dream was, you know, ownership of one's self and pride in one's self. To me, I realized the dream in my own, in my little capacity. And if scholars are writing Mackissac out of history because they don't see him as a hero, well, they're certainly not going to convince Doris Terry Williams or Jane Ball Grum. I mean, I remember walking around with that hat on, we had this cowboy hat or whatever you
系统，行驶在那些道路上，住在那些房子里。简·鲍尔格鲁姆依然拥有她在“灵魂城”的家。我的意思是，对我来说，麦基西克的梦想是，你知道的，对自我的掌控以及对自我的骄傲。对我来说，我在自己的能力范围内实现了这个梦想。如果学者们因为不把麦基西克视为英雄而将他从历史中抹去，那么他们绝对无法说服多丽丝·特里·威廉姆斯或简·鲍尔格鲁姆。我的意思是，我还记得戴着那顶帽子到处走，我们有这顶牛仔帽还是随便你怎么称呼它，那是一顶漂亮的帽子。他就是不会告诉你……简·格鲁姆？你还好吗，简？我很好，麦基西克先生。他关心人们。他就是不会……行吧，格鲁姆，好吧？我很好，我只想说，好吧。他关心人们，他知道他们真的很关心人们。他只是，他并不完美，但他很伟大。是的。
want to call it, it was a beautiful hat. He was just not going to tell you. Jankrum? You okay, Jank? I'm okay, Mr. Macchiss. He cared about people. He was just not going to take a tan, dang room, okay? I'm okay, I'm just gonna say, okay. He cared about people, he knew they really cared about people. He was just, he wasn't perfect, but he was mag-nificent. Yeah.
是的。别给我那种生活。来给我生活吧，多么可爱珍贵的梦想啊，年轻、给我生命，向像我这样的人敞开心扉。
Yeah. Don't give me that life. Come give me life, oh what a lovely precious dream To be young, give me life, open your heart to world like me 99% Invisible was produced this week by Katie Mingle with Delaney Hall, Avery Trufflement, Kurt Colesstead, Sharif Usef, Sam Greenspan, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Megan Reed. The archival tape you heard of Floyd McKissick came from the Southern Oral History Program Collection at the University of North Carolina Chapel Hill.
本周的 99% Invisible 由凯蒂·明戈与德兰妮·霍尔、埃弗里·特拉夫曼、库尔特·科尔斯特ッド、谢里夫·优素福、萨姆·格林斯潘以及我罗曼·马尔斯共同制作。特别感谢梅根·里德。你听到的关于弗洛伊德·麦基西克的历史音频选自北卡罗来纳大学教堂山分校的南方口述历史项目收藏。
We are a project of 91.7KALW San Francisco and produced out of the offices of Arxivine, an architecture in interior's firm. In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook, you can follow us all on Twitter and Instagram, but the best way to explore the 99% invisible activity that shapes the design of our world is to spend as much time as possible on 99pi.org. Radio tapio.
我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，制作于位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽街区的建筑与室内设计公司 Arxivine 的办公室。你可以在 Facebook 上寻找并点赞本节目，你可以在 Twitter 和 Instagram 上关注我们，但探索塑造我们世界设计的 99% Invisible 活动的最佳方式，是在 99pi.org 上花尽可能多的时间。电台台标。
From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自 PRX。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。